[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
would you like to hear an amazing fact
in 1958 one of the worst environmental
disasters in history took place in China
Mao Zedong the communist leader of the
People's Republic of China launched a
campaign ordering that all of the
sparrows in the country were to be
killed
Mao thought that the sparrow spread
disease and ate too much grain it seemed
rational to him that of all the sparrows
were eradicated it would increase food
supplies soon after the whole nation
waged war on the little birds people
tore down Sparrow nests and shot
sparrows down from the sky they poisoned
them and even used beating drums to
scare the birds from landing this forced
them to fly until they died of
exhaustion schoolchildren were rewarded
for bringing in the largest number of
dead sparrows there's no exact
information but it's estimated that
hundreds of millions were killed the
result of the campaign was that they
nearly pushed the little birds to
extinction in China the following year
this led to an immense problem while it
is true that sparrows eat a little grain
they mostly eat insects
after the sparrows were wiped out locust
and other pests populations exploded
eating everything in their path grain
production in China totally collapsed
leading to the deadliest famine in
modern times it's estimated that between
1959 and 1961 about 25 million people in
China starve to death you know the Bible
says that God has a lot to say about the
importance of sparrows stay with his
friends were going to learn more as
amazing facts brings you this edition of
Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at
1-800-805-3030
and our co-host pastors Jean Ross
welcome friends to Bible answers live
this is a live international interactive
Bible study and we invite you to call in
with your Bible questions lines are open
right now wide open if you'd like to
call in with a Bible question here's the
number 800 for six three seven two nine
seven one way you can remember it is
just 800 god says because the Bible is
our text book that's 800 for six three
seven two nine seven or 800 God says
brings your Bible question into the
studio and calling now good chance you
get your question on tonight's program
and we are live my name is Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross and good
evening friends pastor Doug it's good to
be back doing our radio program here but
before we start let's have a word of
Prayer you Father we thank you for the
opportunity that we have to open up your
word and study together this very
important book that relates to every
aspect of life we pray your blessing on
those listening be with us here in the
studio in Jesus name Amen amen
a fast that I do open the program by
talking about this terrible war that was
raged against sparrows of all things and
actually it led to some terrible results
there in China yeah you know you would
think that people realize there's sort
of a delicate balance in nature they say
when the cats are away them mice will
play and they once waged a war against
cats in Europe because they associated
them with the occult and the rats
proliferated and that's when the bubonic
plague came about here they wage war on
sparrows it seems like that would be
pretty difficult but you know it's a lot
of people in China and they virtually
eradicated all of the sparrows and then
the natural predators for all these bugs
we're not there and the bug populations
just exploded and that ultimately was
connected with it was that in some bad
weather cycles that just the biggest
famine I've read about that famine in
China and you know the Chinese official
estimates is 15 million people that's
staggering but the most historians say
it was much bigger than that and it's
only I was alive when this happened as
it's just hard to believe this was only
you know 60 years ago in modern times
that you would have 30 million people
starve to death from hunger in non-war
conditions because they didn't realize
the importance of sparrows you know the
Bible says quite a bit about sparrows
old a New Testament David sings about
them and Jesus talks about them you can
look at Matthew chapter 10 verse 29 and
it says are not two sparrows sold for a
copper coin and yet not one of them
falls to the ground apart from your
father's will
and so you can see that when they killed
millions of them in China
it says not even a sparrow falls to the
ground God feeds the sparrows the Bible
says and he'll take care of us you know
you look at the delicate balance that we
see in creation and it helps us begin to
realize this could never evolve by
accident there's so many symbiotic
relationships that all of nature depends
on everything from you know the little
hummingbirds that pollinate certain
flowers to the the bees that you know
pollinate all the crops and if you'd
like to know more about the incredible
evidence of God that we see in creation
we have a special free offer for you
tonight
we have a book that's entitled amazing
wonders of creation that is a free offer
for this evening you'd like to receive
it give us a call just ask for it
it's called amazing wonders of creation
the number to call is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
that is a resource phone line the number
again is 800 eight three five six seven
four seven ask for the book amazing
wonders of creation if you have a Bible
question I've online here to the studio
is 800 God says that's 800 four six
three seven two
nine seven right one more time you ready
here it is 804 six three seven two nine
seven that'll bring you right here into
the studio with your Bible question
we're gonna go to our first caller this
evening we have Steve listening in st.
Elena Steve welcome to the program hey
you hi thanks on your question what type
of stone were the Ten Commandments
written on what type of stone you know
the Bible doesn't tell us whether it was
granite or emerald or some people
believe that it was
oh not Jasper what's that other stone
was blue yeah anyway there yeah my brain
is going blank but the it said they
believe it was a blue stone and that's
because that color boo blue for the
Levites was compared to loyalty it
doesn't say what the kind of stone was
it probably something that was native to
the Arabian Peninsula there in the
mountains so all I could do is speculate
just says stone so - I read a verse and
Exodus chapter 24 through 10 and they
sold in God of Israel and there was
under his feet as it were a paved work
of sapphire stone no that's itself the
very heavens and his clarity yeah some
say because of that verse they wonder if
the Ten Commandments were written on
sapphire but could be it's just there's
nothing that says the Ten Commandments
were written on sapphire I have no
problem with the person believing that
and of course the first set of tables of
stone God wrote and made those first
tables but then after they were broken
Moses was told to chisel out the stone
and God wrote the Ten Commandments on
that so whatever kind of stone was
available to Moses to chisel out two
tables we don't know whether there was a
lot of sapphire in the area or where
there was a different kind of granite
yeah does that help a little bit with
your question not really because like it
wouldn't make sense why I would choose
like uh like a regular stone like a
sapphire even his like Ezekiel
television and like Ezekiel chapter 1
verse 26 yeah and in the vision does
Ezekiel mentioned sapphire again or he
talks about the the glory around the
throne of God now let me ask this
question does this make a difference
what color the stone was like um if it
wouldn't be sapphire then how come God
chose God's law to be blue represent
blue well but what difference would it
make to you in your relationship to
Christ what color the stones were or
what they're made out of the ten
commandments are important but ya know I
I know I agree and I have no problem
believing it was sapphire I'm just
saying that when it comes to obeying the
law does it make a difference what kind
of stone they're written on if the Ten
Commandments are written on paper in
your Bible are they just as important
yes they are important they're just as
important as if they're written on gold
or if they're written on paper he wants
them written on your heart that's the
important thing
yeah so link so you know you're not sure
what don't well I'm just telling you the
Bible does not say the Ten Commandments
were written on sapphire or emerald or
Ruby or it doesn't say what it was so I
don't have a problem if it was sapphire
I just can't add to what the Bible says
there you know we do have a study guide
that I think would go right along with
this question it's called written in
stone and it's about to take the perfect
yeah
web app to send it to anybody who calls
and asks the number is 883 five six
seven four seven you can answer this
study guy talking about the Ten
Commandments called written
in stone that is a resource phone line
883 five six seven four seven if ever
bible question a phone line here to the
studio is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven eight hundred four
six three seventy two and ninety seven
next caller that we have is low
listening in North Carolina law welcome
to the program hello this is low can you
hear me yeah you're on the air Lowell
thanks for calling
great great alright I've heard some talk
lately about how the ancient Israelites
kept the Sabbath based on an ancient new
moon calendar where reset every new moon
and then they count their seven days
after that so that it would necessarily
be in a different day depending on the
month and that that got changed after
the Romans took over do you have any and
so therefore the seventh-day Sabbath
might not have been on the same Saturday
like we think of today do you have any
opinion on that or have you heard
anything in that regard yeah I have in
and I don't think there's much Bible
support for that you know for one thing
you've got a nation of Jews around the
world that since antiquity they have all
been in perfect agreement all the way
from the time of Exodus through the
Babylonian captivity through the Roman
dispersion Jewish communities scattered
around the world all agree that it was
every seventh day of the week it's set
by a weekly cycle not by a lunar cycle
and because if if it was the other way
it just cut it would discombobulated
your you know when the the Sabbath it
wouldn't be in a cycle of sevens anymore
yeah that's what I was thinking it'd be
hard to keep track of yeah so I've heard
that theory I don't think as much
there's not a lot of support behind it
from I don't know any scholars that
believe that and right yeah you know you
know like you said the Jewish scholars
have been tracking it for centuries
millennia actually 2,000 years right
well of course if we go back about two
thousand years to the time of Christ he
kept the seventh day as
but if there were ever a change he would
have at least noted it or said something
but since the time of Christ has been
accurate records of which day of the
week is the Sabbath and its continued
week after week yeah it's and they run
the Roman they run Roman calendar by
then - weren't they
yeah well the weekly cycle goes back way
before the Roman calendar had an effect
so no matter what happens to the
calendar it never changes the weekly
cycle the days matter of fact you can
write the u.s. Naval Observatory and
they'll tell you that from as far back
as they know in recorded history no
change the calendar has ever affected
the continuity of the weekly cycle so
people think because they look at a
calendar they see the seven days of the
week up there and then they say the
month there they think change you want
to fix the other the days have continued
to go one two three four five six seven
one two three four five six seven since
antiquity and virtually all of the world
has operated under a seven-day week
which to me I think is sign of the
divine origin of it because while some
of the different countries of the world
had varying calendars they're all
somewhat based on the lunar cycle and
our years even though the years of
different cultures were a little
different so I'm at 358 days I'm at 370
days they were based on the sun's cycle
but there's nothing in the Sun Moon or
stars that gives you a seven-day week
except the Bible and yet nations around
the world all had a seven-day week so I
think that's strong proof for that hey
thank you very much for your question
tonight yeah it's called the last day in
history talks about the Sabbath and
gives a little bit of the history of the
Sabbath it's free just call us on our
resource phone line it's eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
you can ask to the study guide called
the last day of history we'll be happy
to send it to anybody who calls and asks
if you have a Bible question our phone
line here to the studio is eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven
eight hundred four sixty three seventy
to ninety seven annex collies Ruth
listening in Massachusetts Ruth welcome
to the program hi
thank you for calling ah thank you my
phone okay with know well we're glad to
hear from you and your question tonight
one question but I could not explain
well but then I made another one is
about the desert temple Tabernacle yes
why do the people find so many water in
the desert to do the services because
they need a lot of wine there
yeah the way they got the water for the
tabernacle services and and not only did
they use water to clean the tabernacle
after you walk past the altar there was
a big piece of furniture that was called
the Laver and it was big enough for the
priests who all washed their hands there
was two different sections of it one for
hands and a lower section for feet and
they had a full-time job keeping the
water running there in fact when they
conquered the Gibeonites the Gibeonites
were told to be servants to bring wood
and water in the sanctuary well in the
wilderness the Bible tells us that
whenever they pitched camp Moses struck
a rock and water would come out of this
rock and it happened on several
occasions at one time they came and they
there was a pool of springs I think that
was called Meribah or um Marah Marah
where they were bitter yeah and then
they healed the water so they had an
oasis at one point but other points it
says the rock that followed them for
scream fiends chapter 10 was Christ they
struck this rock and water came out it
was a miracle just like the bread from
heaven so that water from this
supernatural spring hour stream was also
I'm sure what the Levites used to supply
the tabernacle but hey we'll help we
thank you Ruth for your question we do
have a study that talks a little bit
about the tabernacle and I think it's
called God drew the plans we'll be happy
to send that to anybody who calls and
ask just asked for the study guide
called God drew the plans all about the
sanctuary and its significance the
number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven you can answer the study
guide called God drew the plans and
again our phone line here is eight
hundred four six three
to 97 if you have a Bible question and
it's Kohli's dawn listening in Florida
dawn welcome to the program hi how are
you doing great thanks for calling first
I want to thank you I absolutely love
listening to you
secondly I want to thank you for
broadcasting live on Facebook that's how
I caught you tonight being on the east
coast of a little bit off our wise right
my my question is I always listen to you
preach and you always refer to a day as
a thousand years okay so how do you pull
it out of the Bible that God made the
earth in in seven days if a day is like
a thousand years and we would be going
to church naturally we don't live seven
thousand years so we can't go to church
once every seven thousand years every
seven thousand Saturdays or whatever but
you and I mean I don't write particular
part I always hear you talk about a day
as a thousand years so I'm trying to
connect the two well that's not open a
thousand years that a week yeah a day a
day being a symbol for a thousand years
is not to be applied to creation because
I believe that God created the world in
seven literal days the Bible says the
evening in the morning were the first
day and you know most of the prophecies
in the Bible you would interpret a day
for a year
using an is it numbers four six and Luke
13 and there's several passages that
tell us that in Bible symbols of
prophecy a day is applied to a year
there's that one place where David
quotes from some 84 races a thousand
years of like a day when it is gone I
just I I don't use it all the time I
just said that you know technically
there's about six thousand years of
history and when we look at the
millennium it's 1,000 years in
Revelation 20 said it's like there's six
days of work for saving man and one day
of rest when we live and reign with
Christ that's the only place I apply
that
possible verse so yeah you know the
verse you're referring to a day for a
year principle is numbers chapter 14
verse 34
we're on prophetic days equal to one
literal year it's also introduced note
that that verse that you're talking
about in 2nd Peter chapter 3 and chapter
3 it's in the context of the second
coming why it says if you're looking at
the second coming in the big picture
sometimes people talk of a great week of
time about 6,000 years the earth is
inhabited and then it's for rest for a
1,000 year during the millennium and the
Saints are in heaven so that's kind of
where the one day with the more these as
a thousand years yeah that's you know
you've got to be careful with the Bible
symbols I know that the there's one
denomination that says the creation
really was seven thousand years because
they have trouble believing that God
could do it in six literal days we
strongly believe that it means just what
it says that Bible says in six days he
created the heaven the earth I don't
think we need to try to make it look
like six thousand years or six million
years as some have done I think God
could do it in six days and every
seventh day we remember that well thank
you Don hey we really appreciate your
calling I'm trying you would enjoy the
special book that we're offering tonight
it's really a booklet but it's a
beautifully written called wonders of
creation and we'll send you a free copy
if you just call the resource line the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you can
ask for the book called wonders of
creation and yes friends we are live on
Facebook this evening we weren't quite
sure to make a big announcement until we
knew for sure that it was up and running
it sounds like it is so if you want to
let your friends know if they want to
participate in our program all they need
to do go just go to the amazing facts
Facebook page I'll be able to see us and
hear us and better just listening but if
you're watching and we'll wave at you
right now a next quarter that we have is
definitely listening from Walla Walla
Tiffany welcome to the program hi thank
you so my question is some friends of
mine talked about how the Holy Spirit is
not part of the God
and meet it kind of a Salvation issue so
I'm kind of wondering how I can
reconcile that yeah I know there's this
is kind of come and gone through history
where people struggle with the Trinity
they usually connected with doubting
that the Holy Spirit is a member of the
Godhead they also believe that Jesus is
sort of a begotten or created God they
say there's a difference between being
begotten and created but the whole idea
as if Christ did not exist at one point
and the father brought him into
existence
it's just arguing about semantics it
would mean he was created now Christ
created all things so he couldn't be
created it says all things that were
made were made by him and the Bible says
in the beginning God created Jesus is
God and what about the Holy Spirit you
find the Holy Spirit the same way from
the beginning to end of the Bible says
in Genesis the Spirit of God moved on
the face of the waters and you go to the
last chapter the spirit and the bride
say come
and pastor Ross and I are working on a
devotional on Revelation right now and
there in the first chapter talks about
from he who was and who is the father
and from the seven spirits before his
throne and from the Sun so it tells you
right there in Revelation first chapter
it identifies and then Christ says when
he the Spirit of Truth has come he will
guide you into all truth for he will not
speak of himself but he will show you
things to come
Christ keeps referring to the Holy
Spirit as he he he he he doesn't say my
spirit he doesn't say the father's but
it is a confusing subject because the
way that the father speaks to us and the
son is typically through this person of
the Spirit so the roles of the father
and the Son and the spirit vary now we
do have a book we can send you that
talks more about that because otherwise
I could catch myself I go on half an
hour about this but let me just say a
few more things the book is called
vicinity yeah the book called the
Trinity is it biblical back to the Holy
Spirit real quick
the Bible says the Holy Spirit can be
grieved we don't grieve in it the Bible
says the Holy Spirit you know he were
by the spirit the Holy Spirit was
guiding the disciples he would say do
this and do that and it's just really
clear especially when you get into the
book of Acts the there's an individual
person to the Spirit mm-hmm so if I
don't understand it completely it's not
a Salvation issue no I want to know the
truth but I don't want to be I'm not
clear I keep trying to study it and I
can't well let me just tell you what God
says first of all Isaiah says as the
heavens are high above the earth so are
my ways above your ways job tells us God
is past finding out so the idea that
we're going to be able to melt down all
the aspects of the infinite God and say
you know here's the spirit he does this
and he does this he does this I mean we
can't even begin to figure where God
came from
can we yes so if we can't dissect all
that I definitely do not think well let
me say one more thing about that some
people brought a lot of Protestants are
very suspicious of anything that
Catholics believe because the
Protestants came out of Catholicism and
they felt like that the Catholics
teachings were influenced by paganism
and because the Catholics believe in the
Trinity they think that to believe in it
must mean that you somehow capitulate
into Catholic theology the word Trinity
is not in the Bible the way that
Catholics view the Trinity is a little
different than the way the Protestants
view it you don't find the word Trinity
in the Bible you don't find the word
millennium in the Bible I looked it up
and you don't find the word Bible in the
Bible but we believe that the I guess
the word biblio says in the original so
you you know you because you you don't
find the word Trinity Trinity just means
try entity it it means different things
to the different churches based on how
they explained it I think it's hard to
disagree that you have these three
unique entities jesus said go baptize in
the name of the Father the Son the
spirit at the baptism of Jesus the
father is in heaven he speaks the son is
in the water being baptized the Spirit
is coming down like a dove you see so
much evidence for these three distinct
unique person
of the Godhead but they are one God in
that they are perfectly United in Hebrew
when you say one Jesus said you know a
man and a woman become one flesh but
they're two different beings and Jesus
told the twelve apostles I pray father
they may be one as you and I are one
well if there were twelve individuals
but he wanted them to be united and so
people get mixed up on that if they
understand the Jewish concept of unity
it's not a problem it's not numerical
quantity it's being United anyway now
I'm starting to give you everything in
the book but just ask for the free book
on the Trinity and we'll be happy to
send it to anyone who wants to better
understand the subject and I'm gonna
Coley's 800 eight three five six seven
four seven you can answer the book
called the Trinity you can also read it
for free online just go to the amazing
facts website just amazing facts dot or
RG and look up the book trinity and you
can read it right there on the web thank
you for your call Tiffany we sure
appreciate that and listening friends
we're just taking a brief break to catch
a breath want to remind you we are
streaming live tonight there's a little
camera set up in the studio you can see
us on the amazing facts Facebook site he
does Google amazing facts Facebook
you'll find that and I'm gonna say
something else
this is embarrassing we're a live radio
and I forget what it was it's happening
more and more friends got a break I'll
have a whole minute and a half to think
about what it was but we'll be back Oh
more questions call us
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
amazing facts began in 1965 with a God
inspired concept
hello this is Joe Cruz on the amazing
facts broadcast facts which affect you
each radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a Bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every walk of life the program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include Bible lessons
in 1986 amazing facts added the medium
of television to its growing outreach
efforts offering soul-winning
evangelistic messages for viewers around
the world
in 1994 pastor Doug Batchelor assumed
leadership of the ministry adding the
Bible answers live call-in radio program
and new ministry TV programs began
airing on multiple networks around the
world for 50 years the driving vision of
amazing facts has been the bold
proclamation of the everlasting gospel
and with a team of evangelists circling
the globe and thousands of men and women
being trained through the amazing fact
center of evangelism program Affco the
ministry is helping God's church see a
rich harvest of souls amazing facts
God's message our mission
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call
[Music]
welcome back listening friends this is
Bible answers live if you joined us
along the way it is a live international
interactive Bible study not only on
these various radio stations tonight
we're streaming also on Facebook at the
amazing facts site and we have some
lines open if you want to call it with
your question 800 God says 800 4 6 3 7 2
I am Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross
and we gonna go straight back to the
phone lines that makes holy is Jay
listening in Georgia for the program
good evening evening thanks for waiting
yes sir my question is simple my son and
I are debating the fact over baptism
whether it has to be water baptism or a
spirit baptism and I told them I think
it should be both but in order what does
you know for as a prerequisite to get
into heaven okay alright you're going to
dive into that now all right if you read
in the Gospel of John chapter 3 Jesus
said in cept you are born of the water
and the spirit you cannot enter the
kingdom of heaven and if you read in
mark chapter 16 verse 16 there jesus
said he who believes and is baptized
will be saved he who does not believe
will be condemned
so baptism is certainly important you
know the last thing Jesus said before he
ascended to heaven is go either for
teach all nations baptizing them in the
name of the Father Son and Holy Spirit
the people said to Peter in Acts chapter
2 men and brethren what shall we do and
the Apostle said repent and be baptized
and you shall receive the gift of the
Holy Spirit so there again you have
baptism water baptism is the ceremony by
which you publicly commit yourself to
Christ it's a symbol of washing away
your sin and based on your confessing
Christ God then sends the Holy Spirit to
live the Christian life so certainly
both are important I think if you only
had one or the other you would have to
have the Spirit baptism there may be
people who accept Jesus on the deathbed
and they can't get in the water
I think Christ I'll give them credit for
his baptism but if a person can be
baptized I don't know why I believer
would not want
okay all right yeah I wasn't you know it
was a thing between me and my son and we
want we don't want to take any chances
so I guess we better get them both done
thank you very much all right thanks so
much and we have a special book we'll be
happy to send you on we do actually
deals with this very subject it's called
baptism is it really necessary and we
want to encourage you to give us a call
J and ask for it we'll be happy to send
it to you for free
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven he in that number is 885 six seven
four seven as for the book called
baptism is it really necessary it's got
all the scriptures and a great study we
happy to send it to anybody who calls
and asks our next caller is John
listening in Georgia John welcome to the
program Hey hello thanks for taking a
call well this much I have a question
for those bathrooms honor to speak with
you tonight sir I will say this much we
know that when Christ comes back he's
coming back
clouds are involved I mean I think
Matthew 24 Matthew 26 Luke 21 you know
x1 and and he's coming back in a cloud
but as I study Revelation him and I'm
getting to my question it appears to me
and I'm really fully convinced maybe you
can clear it up and unconvinced me but
it appears to me with when we see Christ
come back in the Earth's atmosphere on a
cloud but that's a big event and then
acts for coming in Revelation 14
starting at verse 14 through 16 crisis
on a white cloud has a shocks a sharp
sickle in his hand and he reaps the
earth in those two verses is this that
the weather called the rapture or the
first resurrection or whatever
terminology terminologies used this
appears to be that to me can you help me
with that but revelation 14 14 through
well the symbols in Revelation first of
all let me back up you're you're right
it does talk about Jesus coming in the
clouds the clouds that Jesus comes in
are clouds of angels
he's coming back the Bible tells us I
think it's also in Matthew it says he'll
send his angels Matthew 24 to gather
together the elect tell us this he's
coming with ten thousand times ten
thousand and when he was caught up into
glory
it's like you know for Elisha they
called it chariots and horses of fire
these are his angels revelation you'll
find Jesus there there's a lot of very
obvious symbols
it's got Jesus coming with a sword
coming out of his mouth it's got him in
one vision he's got a sickle another
place he's got a statement written on
his thigh that says you know Word of God
so I don't think that all the symbols
that you see in Revelation you know are
telling us that you know he's really
coming with a literal sickle because
he's not a farmer I mean he's not gonna
be 4i right mowing people down like
there's a symbol that he's coming for
the harvest of the earth but he is
coming with clouds you can the angel
said to the disciples in Acts chapter 1
the same Jesus will return as you saw
him go they saw him leave he was
received up into these clouds of light
and he's gonna come again in the glory
of the Angels and of course you you
asked the question is this a Revelation
chapter 14 14 through 16 connected with
the rapture it is a description of the
second coming of Christ now what's
interesting about this passage is you'll
notice there's nothing secret about the
second coming of Jesus talks about Jesus
coming there's the harvest of the earth
you read on star in verse 17 the
righteous are gathered and take you to
heaven the wicked are destroyed so yeah
if you study what the Bible says about
the second coming of Jesus there's
nothing secret there's a great
earthquake there's a resurrection that
takes place the righteous are changed in
a moment in a twinkling of an eye and
the wicked are destroyed with the
brightness of his coming so you know
there's a little confusion as to what
exactly is gonna happen when Jesus comes
but there's so many passages in
Scripture that talk about the second
coming has been a glorious event no
one's gonna miss it yeah and then yes
and then a very next chapter
there's things around the throne of God
so I really hold dear to that 14
revelation 14 14 and and a wonderful
wonderful glorious event and again the
the people who got in the throne of God
in the very next chapter and then the
wrath is poured out after that so so
anyway I just I just wanted to kind of
mention that I know different maybe
different teachings on that but but uh
but thank you all for taking my question
I appreciate yeah absolutely now we do
have a book that talks about a study
that talks about the coming of the Lord
and the glory in the clouds and the
pastor Ross pull anything about secret
and we'll be happy to send it to anybody
who calls and asks again it's called
anything but secrets all about the
second coming of Jesus and we'll be
happy to send that to anyone who calls
the number to call is 800 eight three
five six seven four seven that is our
resource phone line as for the book
called anything but secret we'll be
happy to send it to you
our next caller that we have is Ken
listening from Florida can you on the
air glances hello hello hi thanks for
waiting
and your question so we was talking this
morning in Sunday school about second
Corinthians 5:8 absent from the body
present with the Lord and I'm a little
confused because I don't know exactly
how many accounts there are in Scripture
of people that have been resurrected but
none of them tell of their experience of
you know in heaven and I was just kind
of like Lazarus you know the Bible says
that you know Jesus that he was sleeping
and I'm just wondering you know do we do
we immediately go into the presence of
the Lord and I just wonder why those
people that were resurrected none of
them spoke of heaven that's a great
question and and I think you're on the
right track when a believer dies if they
die in a safe condition obviously
believer would be their next conscious
thought is coming out of the grave at
the second coming you read about that in
1st Thessalonians 4 the Lord will
descend from heaven with a shout the
voice of the Archangel the dead in
Christ will rise but for them it's a
moment the twinkling of an eye it's like
you go to sleep and all the Sun the
alarm goes off and and it's an instant
for them so for a believer who dies
their next conscious thought is the
presence of the Lord
but right now they're asleep the Bible
tells us that like Jesus said to Lazarus
the dead sleep until the resurrection
and you read also even Martha when she
talked to Jesus about her dead brother
she said I know he'll rise in the
resurrection on the last day and she was
right
so they'd listen to Jesus teach on this
many times so I think six times in John
chapter six he talks about the
resurrection in the last day so
believers are sleeping a dreamless sleep
they're not conscious of any passing of
time you know I just thought of verse
Ecclesiastes chapter 9 verse 5 says for
the living know that they will die but
the dead know nothing it's not until the
resurrection at the resurrection while
the same coming that the resurrection
takes place yeah so you are correct
there are about a dozen resurrections in
the Bible that are mentioned there's
about three in the Old Testament and
about nine in the New Testament
none of those resurrected ever comment
on either being rescued from hell or
plucked from heaven or anything you know
people point to the parable of the rich
man and Lazarus and they try and build a
doctrine on that but it's just a parable
and so look like Lazarus I mean he had
dinner with Jesus after he was
resurrected correct yeah in Bethany and
you know he spoke nothing about it I you
know if today somebody came back from
the dead every news agency in the world
would send a representative and they'd
push a microphone in his face and say
what did you see everyone wants to know
what happens when you die the very fact
there is no comment on this at all in
the Bible is the Bible says the dead are
reserved unto the day of judgment so
they're not people don't die and go
right to heaven or help before the
judgment they don't go right to heaven
or hell before the resurrection people
get confused because they forget that
there's no consciousness of time for the
dead we experience Abraham and Moses and
and all the one disciples and this and
that everybody is still well there's no
there's a couple of exceptions yet most
of them are but Elijah went to heaven
and if I
Ricci read he's there Moses was
resurrected you can read about that in
the book of Jude Enoch walked with God
God took him there are a few exceptions
but the majority people will be in the
general resurrection at the coming of
the Lord you know somebody in Acts
chapter 2 verse 33 that we're talking
about this to some degree and here's an
interesting verse acts 234 it says david
the patriarch David the King for David
did not ascend into heaven so you know
David had been dead for a number of
years by the time of year - Acts chapter
2 but there it states that David is not
in heaven he's in the grave waiting for
the resurrection and a few verses
earlier it says David is dead and buried
and his grave is with his to the day so
it says he's dead buried not in heaven
it's like how much clearer can you be
david is sleeping David said David slept
with his father's the Bible says so
David will be in the resurrection but
that's 3,000 years ago he died it's not
going to seem like 3,000 years for him
for him to be absent from the body he's
gonna sense a resurrection okay and I
appreciate that and count on just the
last follow up here heaven has already
been created it's already perfect in its
place so right now all of in its glory
it's just not very populated there's
only a few people there Christ said I go
to prepare a place for you now if if all
the patriarchs before Jesus went right
to heaven then their places wouldn't
have been prepared yet but Christ said I
go to prepare a place for you and he
says when I'm done he said I will come
again that's John 14 and so he hasn't
come back yet I don't think all the
places are prepared I think that's
somewhat of a metaphor - he's saying you
know I'm intervening for you in heaven
of course heaven is not empty because
that's where all the angels are but in a
few that would translate without seeing
death but ultimately it's at the second
coming when the righteous get their
reward right now I think of when God
spoke the world into existence I mean it
was immediate so when when Christ said I
go to prepare a place for you I don't
think he's laboring with hands and
building with bricks you know I'm
thinking that you know it yeah he could
snake it into existence but then again
he is a carpenter so na misty's thanks
for your
I'll call and get some literature yeah a
study guide called all the dead really
dead deals with the subject will be
happy to send it to you or anyone who
calls an ass it's 883 five six seven
four seven just ask for the study guide
call other dead really dead
808 three five six seven four seven we
actually have a website also dealing
with the subject called death truth calm
and just Google at death truth calm and
you'll be able to get a lot more
scriptures on the subject annex collies
Edward listening from Bronx
Edward welcome to the program good
evening evening question the god I would
press the regarding Luke chapter
thirteen one through five okay another
hearts and by Jesus we resent unless you
repent ye shall all likewise perish and
also is he is he saying that you if you
repent you would not suffer the state
that the Galileans suffered or the other
people well just to give everybody
listening in the context some people
came to Christ and they said you know
did you hear about the terrible thing
that happened the wall fell on some
people in Galilee and a number of them
died and they must and they're thinking
that a number of they must have done
something terrible for that judgment to
happen and Pilate had also sent some
soldiers into the temple to quell a
rebellion and a number were slaughtered
and they said oh well that those people
died because they must have had terrible
sins and Jesus said do not think that
they were sinners above others but
unless you repent you will all likewise
perish in other words everybody has
sinned so when some judgment befalls if
a plane falls out of the sky we
shouldn't assume well that's because
everyone on the plane they were just
terrible sinners and so they got some
extra special catastrophe yeah the good
and evil perish in a war and good and
evil perish in I mean there's some good
people that may die and what a boat goes
down or you know what I'm saying so
Christ was letting them know that
everybody is guilty of sin and everybody
must repent and but if we do repent and
confess our sins and believe in Jesus we
will be saved
so does that help answer your question
yes it does thank you very much all
right hey thanks so much for calling my
next call is Rodney listening in West
Virginia Rodney welcome to the program
yes thank you for taking my call it's an
honor to speak with y'all
likewise and I have a question about a
movie that I have watched three times
this week and every time I want you to
get more and more intrigued by it I hope
it's the final movie sail the world and
there was an event in there that
happened that they had set a date for
Jesus to return to come back oh yeah and
and that never happened and so the next
day they were experiencing great I don't
know a disappointment or whatever right
and in the process of them study and to
find out what was wrong they found out
that something did occur on that date
and and I was a little bit confused
about exactly what what it was they said
something about it wasn't Ian but it was
the beginning yeah and something about
Christ
it was the sanctuary or something like
that and I was wondering if she could
just explain a little bit about that
event yeah I'll be happy to and I think
the movie you're talking about is
docudrama called go tell the world and
it talks about the Advent movement that
happened in the 1830s and 1840s where
hundreds of thousands of people around
the world and in North America all
believed based on a prophecy in Daniel
chapter 8 where it says in Daniel 8 to 8
14 2300 days then the sanctuary will be
cleansed well they all calculated that
date it gives the starting point in
Daniel chapter 9 and they said well
starting point is the command to rebuild
Jerusalem 2300 years will be 1844
sanctuary being cleansed Jesus must be
coming and everybody thought Jesus was
coming and not just Christians even the
Baha'i faith studied the same prophecy
came to 1844 when Jesus didn't come they
called it the great
appointment now let me just say this was
called the Advent movement people have
often confused this saying well that was
the seventh-day Adventist Church
seventh-day Adventist Church did not
exist back then these were mostly Sunday
keepers it was Baptists and
Presbyterians and Advent means anyone
who believes in the Advent or coming of
Jesus and so this was the great Advent
movement among Protestants and they
continued to study they realized you
know the dates were right the event that
they foresaw was wrong nothing in the
Bible says that the earth is the
sanctuary but the bible does say in
Hebrews God has a sanctuary in heaven
where they believe Christ entered his
final work as our high priest of
cleansing the sanctuary it's like in
Revelation you've got seven ages of the
church the last age of the church is
called Laodicea the judging of the
people that we entered the last age of
the church and a number of Protestants
of ascribed to that and that's probably
what you're talking about me yeah so we
have a lesson that talks about that
prophecy in Daniel chapter 8 would you
like a free copy that I sure would
it's called God sets a date for the
judgment is that right pastor Ross I am
looking for the exact wording of it here
Preston you know we've some of the
lessons have been revised and and the
creative editors changed the title it
messes us up we always remember the old
titles but you call and you ask for the
book on God sets a date for the judgment
and our operators got it
we got the new name it's called right on
time judgment right on time and we'll be
able to send that to anybody who calls
and ask the number is 883 five six seven
four seven you can ask the study guide
called right on time I'll be happy to
send it to anybody who calls an ass one
more time it's 808 three five six seven
four seven my next call is Ken listening
in Tennessee ken 100 Bible answers life
yes good afternoon gentlemen
thanks for waiting and your call your
Christian yakin Jeremy yes okay my
question is related to Ephesians 4:29 I
would like to know um is it a stand to
use profanity to cuss
and also the reason I acted I was
looking at one of my favorite
motivational speakers and he started
he's starting to cuss now on my Tony
Robbins and I was just wondering is that
is that a stand to cuss or kind of
Christian cuz no one is listening what's
your take on that well use the pen where
the Bible says whatever things are pure
and Noble was a philippians pastor ross
whatever things are pure and Noble and
just and good and holy think on these
things so it never does us any good and
you know it's so pervasive in our
culture I remember when I was a kid I
grew up in New York City I went to
public school and I do your dirty words
every now and then it wasn't it wasn't
very common even in New York City in
public school when I was a kid it's like
people would go whoa listen to what they
said there was a big deal now it is so
omnipresent but it still makes me cringe
whenever I hear you know we don't need
to cheapen our communications by using
dirty words and creating mental pictures
in people's minds why would you want to
create ugly pictures in people's minds I
think it lowers a person's perceived IQ
it doesn't matter if you're tony robbins
or who you are if you've got a resort to
using profanity to make a point it just
means that you're having a problem
thinking of good words and so you're
trying to punctuate your your comments
with profanity and obviously st. using
profane language speech is a gift what
would Jesus do do we ever picture Jesus
talking like that
at Christians a follower of Christ so
you know by all means let all your
conversation be pure yeah Philippians 4
verse 8 yeah and jesus said don't swear
by heaven or by earth let your yes be
yes and you know me no you don't need to
go blankety-blank yes so you know and
that's what they're doing and so yeah
there's our boy you can't hardly see
anything that without bleeping out
comments everything's bleep bleep bleep
please
even the news reports all right hey
thank you I appreciate your question my
next call E is Clare Clare welcome to
the program you on the air
yes hi I'm gentlemen how are you good
thank you for calling thank you for
having me um yeah my question is it's
about Ezekiel 33:3 I was sleeping one
night after after my enlightenment by
the Lord and he had woken me up from my
sleep and I guess it would be the
audible voice of God said Ezekiel 33:3
and it was a voice and I mean it woke me
up out of my sleep I'm just concerned
about the the actual you know the sword
I went to the Bible and it said you know
the the sword is just you know when the
sword comes upon the land sound the
alarm and warn the people so is that
something we should be concerned about
because it was audible and I don't
thinking it was from God
well it's a very important message
that's given in ezekiel chapter 33 it's
talking about the message of the
watchman on the wall meaning that not
only ezekiel who is a prophet but when
god's people know the truth and we know
there is a judgment coming when the
sword was coming it meant an army was
coming judgment was coming to god's
people that a watchman had a
responsibility to tell people to get
ready for this coming battle get ready
for this coming judgment and if the
watchman did not warn them not only
would the people suffer but the watchman
had their blood on his hands because he
was supposed to blow the trumpet and
tell them get ready
we as Christians know that Christ is
coming we have a message to go to the
world and tell them hey get your
priorities straight nothing is more
important than preparing for eternity
this life is really insignificant
compared to the life that lasts forever
and people get so preoccupied with the
cares of this life Jesus tells us in
mark chapter 13 about the second coming
he says watch watch watch watch
so I don't know what the Lord was
telling you but I know that this passage
that he directed you to it's talking
about every believer being a faithful
watchman and when God gives us
opportunity to talk to others about the
importance of eternal preparation
so would this also be about like because
I did have a heavenly encounter as well
about being on that wall of Peter you
know and you know the foundation on that
on that's on that rock
you know the gods building the church on
yeah well if we every believer who is
trusting in the word is building on the
rock you know it says there in Matthew
that the wise men builds on the rock
what does the rock he that hears these
words of mine and does them you know
it's interesting specifically talking
about Ezekiel here and the verse that
you're referring to
it's easy of a prophetess living at a
time when the Babylonians were coming up
against Jerusalem and he was sounding
the alarm that judgment is coming upon
the city many of those in the city
ignored the judgments of Ezekiel and
didn't listen well you know we find a
similar thing back in the days of Noah
know warned about a coming flood and the
people ignored him and so just before
the final judgment that's coming upon
the earth a message needs to be given
and unfortunately it seems that the
majority of the world is not paying
attention that's right
hey we really appreciate your call and
you know we do have a study guide that
talks about the second coming and I
think that our brother would really
appreciate that if you call and ask for
the study guide called the ultimate
deliver ultimate deliverance yes
listening friends it just would not be
fair if we took another caller right now
there I knew it was coming and that
would have been a really short question
but you know before we go to our closing
announcements I just want to remind
everybody that you can listen to these
programs all week long if you even go to
amazing facts dot o-r-g
we've got gobs and tons and rules of
Bible study resources indeed you can go
to youtube the amazing facts channel
scores hundreds of videos and some have
over a million hits so check us out and
we'd love to hear from you keep us on
the air god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
amazing facts through your faithful
support has had a major impact on some
of the largest non-christian locations
in the world beyond the Great Wall the
printing and translation of our books
and video materials are in constant
motion southeast Ohio faith oxygen Tian
Shan Java China - the amazing facts
Chinese language website is now one of
our most visited websites we also
translated thousands of pieces of
literature for these nations what
started out as hundreds of followers is
now in the hundreds of thousands the
impact of your funds invested in sharing
the everlasting gospel in these foreign
lands will be felt for years to come
you know every week we hear the most
incredible stories from all over the
globe
of lives that are being changed and
hearts that are being transformed by the
power of the word and none of it could
happen without your teamwork with this
ministry god bless you I really wanted
to start a new devotional habit but life
got in the way next thing I know we're a
month into the new year and I'm like
what's the point of starting then I saw
365 amazing answers to big Bible
questions each day is a single study so
you can start anywhere on any day and
not miss a thing
their crisp clear and enlightening
[Music]
get yours today by calling